ich glaub ich das mal so formulieren
darf wir werden in der politischen
debatte und auch in der medialen debatte
nach dieser corona lage alle miteinander
viel verzeihen müssen weil das glaube
ich in der bundesrepublikanischen
geschichte noch nie es gegeben hat dass
unter so großen unsicherheiten in so
kurzer zeit so weitgehende
entscheidungen getroffen werden mussten
und da ist es ziemlich normal finde ich
dass solche entscheidung immer wieder
auch eine debatte brauchen und immer
wieder eine adjustierung brauchen und
das nicht von vornherein immer alles
richtig gewesen sein kann das ist eine
debatte die gehört dazu und das sind
debatte die wir auch führen müssen
aber ich finde wir sollten auch
gemeinsam dieses verständnis miteinander
haben nein darum geht es überhaupt sie
machen das jetzt schon wieder genauso
wie man es nicht machen sollte
ich finde nein das geht ja auch für
mediale ich weiß nicht ob sie in ihren
kommentaren nach ja in einem halben jahr
feststellen werden dass sie immer
richtig lagen weiß ich nicht ob alle
virologen alle hygieniker alle
wissenschaftler feststellen werden in
sechs monaten dass sie immer richtig lag
und auch die politik und auch ich
persönlich werde nicht verstellen den
sechs monaten das sich in jeder lage
immer richtig lag sondern unser
gemeinsames bemühen ist doch in seiner
zeit von unwägbarkeiten in so einer
situation von völlig neuen
entscheidungen und mit einer sehr
dynamischen lage immer die bestmögliche
entscheidung zu treffen
mit dem west verfügbaren informationen
und das finde ich einfach ganz generell
wichtig für all die debatten ich hab das
ausdrücklich grundsätzlich gemeint und
wege darauf auch wird